samuel paty et est professeur d'histoire
géographie dans un collège des yvelines
pour avoir enseigné l'esprit critique
éveiller les consciences de ses élèves
et transmis les valeurs de la laïcité
il a été lâchement assassinés
aujourd'hui toute la nation pleurs
samuel pâtit il y à l'homme le père de
famille victime de la violence barbare
qui laisse derrière lui une famille et
des proches en deuil
il y à l'enseignant tombés au combat
pour la liberté
après avoir consacré sa vie au service
de ses élèves et oeuvrer avec courage à
leur émancipation
il y à l'islamisme radical qui à travers
samuel pâti cette attaque et au plus
beau symbole de ce que la france a
apporté au monde
l'humanisme des lumières lors de
l'hommage national qui lui est rendu par
la nation à la sorbonne
nous réaffirmons collectivement notre
attachement absolu à la liberté
d'expression et à la laïcité qui sont au
fondement de notre pacte républicain
nous disons toute notre affection et
tout notre soutien à la communauté
éducative à ces femmes et à ces hommes
qui luttent pied à pied contre
l'obscurantisme
nous réaffirmons avec force que nous ne
céderons pas devant une idéologie qui
conteste ses principes et qui les
utilise trop souvent pour mieux les
affaiblir nous redisons à l'ennemi que
nous continuerons de le combattre en
france et dans le reste du monde
mais les mots ne suffiront pas la peur
doit changer de camp
comme l'a rappelé le président de la
république pour que l'école sanctuaire
républicains ne soit plus jamais la
cible du fanatisme pour que les
enseignants continuent de transmettre
les valeurs de tolérance et de respect
ils doivent être mieux accompagner et
protéger
nous devons aussi reprendre la main sur
les réseaux sociaux qui ont joué un rôle
funeste dans le tragique destin de
samuel pâtit nous devons enfin exercer
un contrôle plus ferme des organisations
qui
une prétexte et libertés publiques pour
mieux en saper les fondements dans
l'esprit du discours prononcé par le
président de la république aux mureaux
nous devons faire démonstration d'unité
car c'est notre arme la plus puissante
pour faire échec à ceux qui veulent s'en
prendre aux trois principes que nous
chérissons par dessus tout liberté
égalité fraternité